rise and shine it's an espresso time
good morning relief nation it's even my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe in that amazing gift you have
inside to you that needs to be shared
with the world so let's start the day
off right together grab your cup of
coffee and sit on today's message set
boundaries
over to you Oprah Winfrey so I first
started making money and it was you know
my salary or my earnings were published
all over the place I mean the first year
I was like really did I make that much
money oh my god it was very difficult
for me to figure out where my boundaries
were because I'd grown up poor and
didn't have anything so it's easy when
you don't have anything and people ask
you for money and they say I need 500
cent I don't have it cuz I'm just trying
to get my rent paid it's harder when
you're multi-billion dollar salary is
now in the paper and you get a lot of
friends and cousins you didn't have
before so how do you set boundaries for
yourself I was having trouble setting
boundaries myself for myself for even
strangers people would just show up at
my door in Chicago and say Oprah I left
my husband please help me and I would
because she knows I have it so don't try
that now though okay don't try that now
I figured it out so what I learned was
is that oh the reason why people keep
showing up is because my intention is to
make them think that I'm such a nice
person
that you can ask me for anything you can
get me to do anything I'm gonna say yes
I'm gonna say yes so when Stevie called
me this time I thought I'd try out my
first no on Stevie let's start big he
wanted me to donate some money to a
charity and I didn't want to donate to
the charity because I have my own
charities and I care about a lot of
people but the problem is when you you
have money everybody thinks you just
want to give to everything so every
letter I ever get starts with we know
you love the children
yes I do love the children but somebody
else is gonna have to help the children
so I said to Stevie I said to Stevie no
and as a person who has that disease to
please I was waiting for him then just
to say I will never speak to you again I
will never call you I will never sing a
song for you and he didn't he just said
okay okay okay it's okay he said okay
check you later and what I learned from
that is many times you will have angst
and worry about things and put yourself
in a state like someone said this
morning cuz their phone went off they
were mortified over a phone I said
really you will put yourself in a state
when the other person really isn't even
thinking about you so learning that I
could specifically determine for myself
what the boundaries were for me what I
wanted to do give my money give my time
given of my service to who I wanted to
give it to when I did that I get to make
that decision and just because you get a
hundred requests a week doesn't mean you
have to try to fulfill all of that just
because you have all of these demands on
your time and on you doesn't mean that
you have to say yes you get to decide
because you're the master of your fate
the captain of your soul is William
Ernest Henley said in Invictus and
understanding that really change the
meaning of my life and that I was not no
longer driven by what other people
wanted me to do but took charge of my
own destiny making choices based upon
what do I feel is the next right move
for me setting boundaries for what you
will and will no longer accept in your
life is one of the most powerful
decisions that you can make ever
your life period when you start to
accept responsibility and say this is my
time I am NOT carving it out for anybody
else unless I want to I am not letting
other people attack my time I am setting
the boundary right I'm setting the gate
I'm building a wall so that to get at me
to get the most precious thing I have it
is time it's gonna be valuable it's
gonna be worth it so many people are
just time for your doing everything and
you feel you have no time for yourself
because you're explaining your time
doing things for other people and that
can be great if it's out of service if
it's out of something that fills you up
and fuels you but if you're spending all
of your time just living somebody else's
dream just all improve for other people
and not having enough time for yourself
to recharge or for you to go off and
follow your dream do the thing that you
want to do you're gonna be unhappy then
you're gonna be unfulfilled then you
need to be constantly playing small and
so what's really important is that you
start saying now that you start sending
values that you start protecting your
time whether it's just blocks whether
you start with just an hour a day from
7:00 in the morning to 8:00 in the
morning this is my time or 7:00 at night
8:00 at night is my time I'm doing this
nobody talked to me phones off like
don't email me don't distract me you
know training the people around you so
what it is you train the people in your
life but this is how you work and you
have to be willing to let go of small
wins to go for the bigger one so as an
example the first one for me was given
up email I used to check email
constantly I used to pride myself on if
you sent me an email
I would respond within one or two
minutes and instantly and every time I
get a reply back see how you respond so
quickly and that fed the negative loop
right like you're giving me you're
giving me a compliment you're giving me
a boost for doing this destructive habit
so I'm gonna do it again and again and
again I call it destructive because
while it helped that one person helped
out with a mic for a moment it
constantly distracting from doing the
big things I could never do a big
project work really deeply on something
creative because I kept getting beep
beep you know kept getting that email
ding going off and I'd be distracted and
so if you're constantly just replying to
social media and answering phone calls
and being in your email you're never
actually doing really really really
important work and so you have to be
willing to let go of
minor wins to spend time on a bigger one
sometimes that means I miss out on
potentially bigger opportunities a media
is a great example there's reporters who
need feedback by a certain time I'm
working on a story my deadline is four
o'clock today I don't see the email till
the next day I missed that I missed on
that that chance to be in that story
maybe that's an amazing story that can
help give me more credibility but I'm
working on something else like in that
time I'm present doing something else
right in my book making some videos
whatever it is I'm not distracted and so
you know you're playing the game that
that focus work that you're spending
time on is going to yield something much
bigger than just being constant
distracted by other people's agendas and
so you need to train the people around
you as another example I run a
mastermind group here in Toronto for
entrepreneurs with 300,000 plus in
revenue and we meet once a month and the
meeting is usually at my condo in the
boardroom and they wanted to change it
up somebody emailed the morning of we
meet at night and the evil in the
morning hey how about meet at my office
I'm moving into a new office how about
we meet there and everybody in the
conversation was responding and say this
is good grade like I can make it I can
make it let's go let's switch it up
let's make it I don't see the email if
you email me the day of I may not get
back to you that day I mean I might get
back to you for two days
because I'm working on important stuff
I'm not getting distracted by something
as little as where we're gonna meet up
tonight and at the end of the day
somebody said hey we're waiting forever
to make a call on it I obviously didn't
make a call and everybody end up showing
up at my place and we decided for the
next month to go meet at that other
person's place but even if nobody showed
up
like everybody went to do the person's
place and I stayed here I'm cool with
that I'm training the people around me
that if you email me on the day of and
then send like 15 follow-up emails I'm
not seeing that I'm not replying to that
I'm busy doing important stuff don't
expect me to handle your crisis I don't
think it's a crisis I'm not being sucked
into your crisis I have important work
to do and so I train the people around
me I don't use a cell phone I have a
phone where's metal I have a phone but
there's no number I have a data package
so I can connect and see what needs to
get done or from bored again it's an
email but
phone number when you have a phone
number then people call you and that is
a just huge time-suck a phone number is
other people's agenda for your time
because even if you don't answer you're
looking at the number music what is that
person one and one the way they're
calling and you get distracted
immediately distracted from what you
were working on if I'm working on my
book and I'm trying to make gold for you
guys or on the middle of this video if
I'm in the middle of recording this
video somebody calls me and I look at it
and I'm just thinking for five seconds
what does that person want I've already
forgotten what I'm talking in this video
I'd start over this person just wasted
my time and wasted all of your time
right
I'm not happy with that so you got to
stop getting distracted you got to start
setting some boundaries and be willing
to give up some small wings because
you're working on much more important
things train the people around you that
your time is important if you don't
treat your own time as important than
the people around you they won't treat
as important either set boundaries and
set yourself free so the question that
today is I'm curious what if the biggest
time-suck in your life in your business
that you now need to set some boundaries
for after watching this video leave in
the comments below really curious to
find that I also want to give a quick
shout out to Kelly from you and Kelly
cue calm Kelly thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book your one
word actually ten copies of the book and
sharing it with your friends I really
really really appreciate the support and
I hope you enjoyed the read so thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
and I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot events best
[Music]
oh I'm great at boundaries I'm not great
at boundaries I'm kidding I so thought
that was gonna be a laugh line I thought
you guys knew me I thought you knew me
well enough to know that no I I don't
have any better I'm the permeable
membrane I don't know I let I let the
you know I'm a little better at it but
but I have I don't know I have learned
one important thing which is that I
think you sort of get to a point in your
life where you think I have to learn how
to say no to things I don't want to do
and that's a big mature moment when you
start to begin to do that but the bigger
mature moment is when you learn how to
say no to things you do want to do
because you know that you just don't
have time or you don't have energy or
there just isn't you know you have to
sort of triage your life and there just
isn't an opportunity and and that only
came to me very recently that sometimes
you you have to turn down even the
wonderful things in order to take care
of your health or to take care of what
you truly truly truly care about not
just what you truly care about there's a
place in you that you must keep
inviolate you must keep it pristine
clean so that nobody has a right to
curse you up treat you badly nobody no
mother father no wife no husband knows
nobody because that may be the place you
go to when you meet God you have to have
a place but did you say stop it back up
not even must not know no absolutely and
that's one I told you 25 years ago
yes say no when it's no yeah say so back
it up because that place has to remain
clean and clear and that has to be a
place within you yes ma'am yeah that is
the best advice it's 8:00 a.m. like I
gotta get to the office and I was like
why like why do I have to get like I I
always wanted to be a writer
I accomplished this thing I could make a
living being a writer I have a home like
I haven't been there in weeks like why
am I here and and I was like I was here
because like I just say
yes and I didn't think about like I mean
I didn't actually weigh like the pros
and cons of this scenario and again it's
like sometimes you got to do it you
don't want to do to figure out what you
want to do but it was like I sort of
distanced myself from a lot of things
and I've gotten got my life in a good
place and then someone called me and
offered me money on the phone and I said
yes alright because it's so hard to say
it like it's so hard to to say notice
stuff like especially if you're like I
do it's so hard to say like I want to do
this but I also want to do that I have
to choose it's easy to say like I'm
gonna try to do both at the same time
and I said yes to both like I don't I
don't think I've ever like quit anything
like I've just added new stuff right and
so for me that certainly has added up
over time to an unsustainable load raise
your standard Apple at the core its core
value is that that people passion and
not one drop of my self-worth depends on
Europe it's something Samia
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or absolutely in faster hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten rows of success I have
a very special secret video for you
these are the individual clips that I
have personally learned the most from
and applied to my life and my business
check the link in description for
details